Finding your inner neanderthal is definitely
the most fun class even though it's only
once a week for two hours, I look forward
to it every week. A different way of
thinking with the past trying to sort of
recreate it and so the idea was let's not
just study the stone tools they made
let's see if we can make them to really
gain an insight on how they did it.
The Peabody Museum has fantastic
collections of Neanderthal-made artifacts
we've been studying them, we've been
looking at even fossil Neanderthals
that are here.
It's a lot of hands-on learning and every week is
something new to look forward to and
a new things we're talking about. Reading
about things is great, but if I can do it,
if I can touch it, if I could feel it,
that is a is a sort of experience that
I don't forget. There's something about
hands-on making your own stone tools and
stuff like that, but we had looked at
pictures of stone tools but you don't
really get a sense of what the process
is like sitting in those chairs and
actually like hammering out the stone
tools. Making stone tools is pretty
tricky. You got to, at first, make sure that
you don't hit your own hand because
that's one of the biggest thing, you've got these
rocks and you just think it's always
just hit it and it'll make a point,
not really. It's almost like the physics
of how you like need to hit certain
parts of a rock to get it to be the way
you want it.
We live in such a technological society
that we lose sense of the technologies
everywhere and so by sort of
immersing themselves in making what in
some ways is the oldest technology, I
think that's a really powerful way to
appreciate the past.